hello can you hear me my name is Karen
Eden I know but I know a fair number of
you in this room it's sort of a dual
role I teach medical decision making I
do research in patient decision aids and
patient decision making and I oversee
the doctoral and postdoctoral program so
I've seen you in many capacities so
today I'm going to talk with you about
our evidence-based decision aids in
women's health how many of you have
heard of a decision aid yeah lots of
people okay so I probably don't need to
put this definition of here but the
decision aid is not designed to make a
decision for you and it's not designed
to replace a discussion with provider
for a patient it's really designed to
help people become involved in
decision-making by providing information
about options by helping the person kind
of work through the issues clarify
values and as I mentioned it's not
designed to remove that visit with the
provider is it's really to help you have
a good fruitful discussion so the
decision is I'm going to be showing
screenshots from today are all designed
using the International patient decision
aids standard and I'm part of this
collaboration and the purpose of this
collaboration is to establish an
internationally approve set of criteria
to determine the quality of patient
decision aids so what does all this mean
this means we need to provide decision
aids that have enough detail that
present things in an unbiased way and is
understand our understandable for
patients that help the patient's work
through the issues and clarify values
and provide some kind of feedback at the
end or structured guidance so I'm going
to show you some screenshots from three
of our aids one is for domestic violence
one is for mammography for women in
their 40s how many of you heard the big
news that broke on Tuesday okay we'll
talk about that a little bit today and
child birth after cesarean so the
domestic violence decision aid is an aid
to help women
for safety after pilot setting we got an
ro1 we deployed this in four states
through the internet and we've just
begun producing our manuscripts with the
with the results the mammography
decision aid is for went to help women
in their 40s first of all find out if
their average risk and then if they are
average risk to help them weigh the
risks and benefits of starting a mog
raphy in their 40s or waiting until
their 50 child birth after cesarean for
the woman who has delivers a baby by
cesarean and what n is ready to have
another child she must decide whether
she wants to schedule a repeat cesarean
or will she try and have a vaginal
delivery alright so in this talk I'm
going to show you some screenshots of
the different ways we help patients
access their assess their own risks
become informed and then set priorities
for the decision and how we provided
feedback so all of our aides have some
kind of a secure login and that way
patients can return to them but again
it's it's something they have access to
only they have access to this is a
screenshot from our domestic violence
decision aid just the self assessment in
this one ask the women a series of 20
questions questions like is there a gun
in the house as he tried to choke you
though the responses to those 20
questions have been validated in a tool
excuse me have been used in a tool that
was validated against homicidal records
to indicate how much danger the woman is
in so as we can see here this woman
scored a 19 she's in a level of danger
somewhere between severe and extreme and
then they get appropriate feedback so we
met with advocates providers and
patients to develop what that feedback
should look like because sometimes when
you see information like this it might
be scary and how are you going to
respond so we had to make certain what
we developed would appropriately engage
the person we also do a risk assessment
for our breast cancer screening decision
aid we called it mammal pad because we
deployed it on iPads and it was for
mammography
we're still working on the name though
so that's what it is now because we
deployed it on mammal pad we couldn't
just throw up 20 questions and how
people go through with radio buttons and
click them so there had to be a series
of questions and these questions are
nested so these are questions about
personal and family history if you say
yes you have personal history of breast
cancer or ovarian cancer it would triage
you to an appropriate message to see
your provider and set up screening if
you indicated that you a family member
had breast cancer then it would ask you
a series of questions to find out how
many family members how old were they
and that sort of thing and these were
these questions are all based on the
brst model so and then women responded
well to these so they use this tool up
front before they had access to the
actual aid the clinics were really
excited because it helped identify women
they didn't know we're above average
risk and in our study about ten to
fifteen percent of women who used our
tool were discovered to be above average
risk so now I'm going to show you some
screenshots of how we inform patients
about their options and the evidence so
the first thing I'll talk about is what
you heard Tuesday so up until Tuesday
most women have been told not all women
but most women have been told start
getting an annual mammogram when you
turn 40 that's if you went to your
gynecologist if you went to your family
medicine doctor who follows the US
Preventive Services Task Force that
doctor might say wait till you're 50 and
then go every other year okay so you
have your gynecologist saying start when
you're 40 go every year you have your
family doctor saying no way to near 50
and go every other wow that's confusing
so what do women do then on Tuesday the
American Cancer Society released new
recommendations moving this back to 45
for their recommendation but encourage
shared decision-making between 40 and 45
both the US Preventive Services Task
Force and the American Cancer Society
encourage shared decision-making for
starting before age 50 so this tool
helps women kind of under
Stan the risks and benefits of that of
whether to start screening earlier and
really it just to remind you it's really
a choice that these women are making
while they're discussing these options
with their providers this is a shared
decision-making opportunity so what we
did is we provided information about
risk in this pictograph that you see one
in 70 women average risk women between
the ages of 40 and 49 will develop
develop breast cancer over a 10 year
time period and we showed this same
pictograph for women in their 50s it was
two out of 70 we also try to convey and
that some forms of breast cancer are
very aggressive and some forms of breast
cancer are or not so what we found is
that we had to really test these
graphics so we had lots of conversations
with women we said look at these
graphics tell us what you see in your
own words and the first time we
developed this graphic we were very
pleased we had this animation we had the
little pink figure moving all around so
we were trying to convey that it was one
out of 70 but we don't know who the one
out of 70 is until the third woman who
used the tool and she said oh my gosh it
as time passes it's going to be me it's
like a ping pong ball pop popping all
around wow that wasn't what we met so we
had to revise how we presented this so
now a pictograph shows like this and
then it fades away and a question mark
comes up and the women seem to
understand what that meant a little
better with this one we originally had
one woman we had half of her body one
color we showed organs affected we show
the bigger tumor on the other side a
little tumor and nothing else affected
again we thought it was really clear
till about the fifth woman used it and
she said I had no idea of breast cancer
on the left side of its wake more
aggressive in the right
so back to the drawing board we needed
to separate figures so we do a lot of
working with patients and providers to
make certain what we're presenting has
face validity and is understandable and
a written in plain language this is
another graphic that we tested with
women we went through a lot of
iterations as Michelle who was on the
team didn't can speak to but in the end
we went with this this graphic that
shows because it wasn't really feasible
to throw us show a thousand pictographs
news thousand figures up on a pictograph
so if we had a thousand women average
risk in their 40s so have a mammogram
today 899 women would have normal
results others 899 there would be one
cancer missed there would be a hundred
and one women who would have abnormal
results I need further imaging of those
101 to cancers would be found and one
precancerous lesion would be found and
so the women did seem to follow this
this diagram they did seem to be able to
track what happens to those thousand
women so in addition to informing doing
a risk assessment and informing we also
want to help the patients process the
information weigh pros and cons of
screening in the 40s versus not we did
this in a variety of ways we started off
in our early prototype with 10 different
attributes of what was important however
look closely at what these are avoid
false positive avoid false negative okay
when we start asking women what these
things were they had no idea even though
we put what we thought were very clear
definitions was still very complicated
and so we worked very hard to come up
with plain language presentation we also
did away with ten things most people
cognitively don't process ten things
very well and so we narrowed it down to
two primary risks to primary benefits
and this is actually three little
screenshots but we asked the women
what's most
important to you please choose the one
benefit that matters most to you in
deciding whether to have mammograms on a
regular basis in your 40s peace of mind
of having a mammogram that shows no
cancer or catching cancer early we might
mean simpler treatment could mean
reduced reduced chance of dying so those
are that they had to pick one of those
two and we asked them to think about the
two harms and which of the which one of
those harms would be most important one
was extra tests and worried from false
alarms having a mammogram that finds
something that really isn't cancer you
know we have 101 women who had to come
back also no improvement or length of
life length of quality of life and
unnecessary diagnosis this is that
overdiagnosis term and they seem to
understand that pretty well and then at
the end we asked them again to look at
the one benefit in the one harm that was
most important to them and pick one for
childbirth childbirth decision aid we
took a slightly different approach all
of our aides have some kind of
underlying model and I wish the witch
the patient's don't see but we we know
that it's behind the interface and we
have a mathematical way to combine the
responses that the patients enter and
setting priorities so in this one this
is the member list we're shifting gears
to having a baby after you've had a
cesarean so the four main criteria that
we learn from the literature and in
interviewing women and providers were
avoid risk to future pregnancy avoid
injury to mother avoid injury to baby
and have desired delivery experience so
the women did a series of pairwise
comparisons and i'm going to show you
those in just a minute and then we took
those comparisons to figure out what the
priority weights were so this is an
example comparison avoid injury to me
versus void injury to baby this woman
has indicated avoiding injury to baby
was three times more important than
avoiding injury to herself if you go
back to this model these are the
priority ways that were computed out of
that activity we give this information
to the women so that they see how
they're prioritize
because you're just asking someone to do
simple ranking doesn't necessarily
convey how important a particular item
maybe there's one driver that's really
driving everything that we really
pushing everything in this case avoid
injury baby we did have took a similar
approach for a domestic violence
decision aid thinking about your
relationship which of these two factors
is what is more important to you my
concern for safety versus having
resources if she moves out she may
suddenly lose her health insurance her
house ability to put food on the table
so this is really hard things to sort
out but we know in here she's doing that
she's thinking about those things we
then give feedback to the participants
in a variety of way so for the pairwise
comparisons if the feedback begins with
just a simple bar chart in this case the
woman was told that you know her own her
child well-being if you had a hunt if
you had 100 pennies 35 of those pennies
would be in the in the child's
well-being bucket 25 would be in safety
for herself and once they see this
feedback they can go back and make
changes once they see their danger level
they may want to go back and make
changes they have the opportunity to
return and do that we then take the
information that they have entered into
the decision aid and we give them a
customized report the customized report
also provides some generic information
this is the general information about
risk but the second page is really you
can't see it I apologize for the teeny
tiny font but it it addresses what's
really most important to the women it it
states out what their concerns are about
mammograms if they have questions they
can we have a pic menu of questions they
can also type in their own question so
it prepares them for that conversation
with a provider when they go in now this
report they can email to themselves they
can email it to a provider we're
currently working with some clinics to
try to integrate this into my chart so
that you know some kind of a snapshot
our small version of this would be
available for the provider to prepare
again for that conversation
so as I just indicated everybody
elements on all three studies got some
kind of report and at the end of the day
when we measured the decision-making
process before and after using the tools
all three of the studies showed
improvement the women felt more informed
had more clear priorities around health
decision felt more supported and
reported overall less conflict about the
decision so these study suggests that
evidence-based decision aids and women's
health improve the decision-making
process after only one session with the
aid however our domestic violence one
they got to use it multiple times during
the year and we are currently
summarizing those results I don't have
those today but those are coming what
are the some of the new work we're doing
is not just for the person who is a
primary decision-maker it's also for the
person who might be helping that friend
or family member in this example we are
deploying a decision aid at college
settings and if a woman has been
assaulted there's often a friend who's
there walking beside her and trying to
help but the friend doesn't feel
equipped so this this particular aid has
to a triage point if you're the friend
or the survivor it kind of sends you off
into the two different directions and it
gives you resources as a friend on how
you can help it and it gives different
resources somewhat different resources
for the for the survivor so that's sort
of new work there's not much work done
in this area yeah I know where I'm
running out of time so i will just jump
quickly to these are the funders and
sponsors for this work nih and has
sponsored a variety of ways to my k12
and also through the NLM fellowship we
also have a large ro1 through the
National Institute of Mental Health and
we have found with receive some
foundation funding and the Oregon rural
practice research network has been very
active in deploying our mammography
decision aid and I think these slides
are going to be available to you if you
know if you want to read more about them
and I think we have like three minutes
left
softsoap questions sure yep so on the
slide you had of the decision aid for
domestic abuse it's not like you're
providing a pretty strong suggestion for
the user to pursue a police report or
consult some sort of authority in some
some way we actually we're careful not
to tell them you know we're careful to
say here are the resources to do that
I'm trying to see that with from the
danger level slide or from Yeah Yeah
right here yeah so the feedback is this
person is was it a fairly high level so
we were encouraging them to seek
resources whether it's an advocate it's
a lawyer or police they don't always go
first to the police sometimes they'll go
to a Support Center but that if they
reach that level of danger they need to
be seeking some kind of resource now I
did spend a day watching the restraining
order process and learning about that
the legal process is not easy and it's
challenging and so not not all the women
will pursue that but the advocate can
help explain to them that process and
our aid if you click on the resources
tells you a little bit about that
process okay I guess my question was I
guess hypothetical example we say it's
critical someone goes to a police to the
police you know in fear of her own
safety if she does that and then her her
abusive partner finds out about it and
becomes very violent towards her is
there any risk of being the target of
litigation or do you guys hold any
liability for anything that can come of
making these suggestions that's a good
question we have had these tools
evaluated for that we also use extreme
care in counseling the women about how
to clear their cash how to remove
history how to use the computer in a
safe location so we've had to take extra
precautions for that reason because we
know there's some stopping behavior
and the user might be looking on the
computer to see well where is you know
my significant been lately so we provide
strong feedback with that we had also
advocates in each of the states who were
personally able to get on the phone and
talk with the women and get them into
the right centers as needed it's a good
question we don't tell them we were
careful never to tell them what to do
what these aids do really say here are
the resources this is an awareness be
aware that you are in danger when we
presented this to a group of judges from
Family Court they wanted to see the
reports for the women who were in our
study I said it can't provide that it's
confidential if the woman chooses to
provide that that's up to her but I
can't we can't provide that for you
that's really up to her good question